hey Rob how are you hey hey I'm doing
good are you doing this I'm good
which team that you root for football
team growing up well what do you I'm uh
you know I grew up in Miami so I'm all
about the youth what about a pro team
we had a great year this year did you
wrap an NFL team were you a Dolphins fan
I'm a Dolphins fan you know it I was
born in Dallas so I'm a Dallas fan
because my parents wouldn't allow me to
you know not be I would be disowned so I
have to be a Cowboys fan but I'm a
Dolphins fan first did you get to meet
Dan Marino Dan Marino he's awesome he's
very nice guy
did you ever want to put any athletes in
a music video I never really thought
about it but a as long as they can dance
my motto
yeah let's see that's the right answer I
I have you there's an assignment for you
by the way the Vanilla Ice project DIY
what season is this for you season eight
yeah nine years running and and just
enjoying every moment this this cut from
coal Beasley he's a cowboy wide receiver
you mentioned you're a cowboy fan so
maybe there's a home court advantage
home-field advantage for him I love you
know what's funny is I'm trying to
envision like Cole Beasley like when you
watch him on the fields in the cowboy
uniform does his stuff and I'm trying to
envision that being him and I just can't
put the two together it doesn't sound
like that would be him but as far as the
rap goes it's pretty good but if I
didn't tell you that was Cole Beasley
does it work against him that I said it
was Cole Beasley therefore you go in
with maybe lower expectations there or
that you know he that this isn't a guy
that you would think would be rabid
right yeah
you'd never think in a million years
like if you played that for everybody
you didn't tell them to it was they
never ever
I can't even still imagine it you know
it doesn't sound like it's what I
envision Kolb's Beasley rappin this but
what are you listening for
well just kind of the flow and see if
they can stay on beat and and and really
the main thing is what are they saying
you know and he had a couple positive
little things in there I'm gonna give it
to my offspring or whatever you know I'm
listening to a little bit of it but you
know we all have kids I think that's
cool but you know I like positive stuff
man
you know you know what's weird is that
when any you know athlete celebrity so -
so to speak does rap music it's really
never taken serious never not in a real
rap world it'll never be taken serious
because anybody can go get a studio and
you know these guys got money they can
go in any kind of great studio and do
some kind of thing you know they've all
tried it you know I think there's only
been one successful it maybe and that
was I think Shaq when he did when he did
it with the Fuji nickens but like you
know they don't really they're not like
really taking serious as a real rapper
you know what I mean so it's kind of
funny to hear him get all serious but
it's still fun and if they like it and
that's their passion and have fun doing
it but the fact that they're already a
celebrity being an athlete is I don't
think it's ever gonna work yeah I I
think it might be a problem though in
the rap community when you're giving
sound financial advice when you say you
ain't taking money then you lost me I'm
saving all that for my offspring can't
snatch a necklace up off me because I
don't have one spent that on college
funds for both my sons see I don't know
right sound financial advice there I
don't know it's kind of you know what
that is that's a catch catch-22 right
there that's that's yeah that's a little
confusing it is you know but hey kudos
to a man I love Cole Beasley he's a
great player and he's the kind of the
go-to player man and every time he made
it made a catch this year everybody was
always cheering and my girl she's got a
cold Beasley shirt so you know they cope
how about you do do that with you how
about you do a duet with Cole visa I'll
do a duet with anybody as long as it
fine I just want to have fun man that's
my whole motto we only live once have
fun doing it
who's the rapper first rattle take that
you liked first rapper I ever liked was
ice tea and I loved ice tea man yeah way
back in the day with colors and you know
I grew up to turbo and ozone
breakdancing and stuff in the movies B
Street you know hip-hop movie so I had a
mirror in my house and I would sit there
and you know do the wave and better
breakdance a little bit and I remember
at 14 years old man I could make like 40
50 bucks a day spinning at the mall
coming in and out and I would spin on a
piece of cardboard with a big jambox and
I can chase the girls around the mall
eat some pizza see a movie and have some
change leftover can you still breakdance
I tried man but you know I'm not as
young as I used to be but I got it for
about two minutes but it hurts after you
know can you can you tweet out a video
of you breakdancing can you can you send
that out I'd love to see it you owe me
okay you got it about to go on the Isle
of the nineties cruise today and I've
got my hair shaved like I'm a teenager
yeah like I got the lines in my hair and
we're gonna go with I'm on the Isle of
the nineties tour with salt and pepper
and Color Me badd and and and tone Lok
and Rob base and Naughty by Nature so
we're gonna have a good time acting like
teenagers out there though I'm prepped
I'll do a little breakdance for you and
send it out I would love it Twitter yeah
I would love that but where is Tom Oak
bin you know he got paid to do the wild
thing and then he left like we lost him
yeah man you know he's doing really good
he went into like television he does a
lot of voiceovers for cartoons and stuff
that you you might not recognize you
know him being in there but you'll
you'll hear his voice you know he's got
a very really distinct voice you know
but he's he's busy elements on the grind
and he's been on the I love tonight he
threw with me for the past year and I
gotta tell you Tony Loki is probably one
of the coolest guys I've ever met in my
whole life just cool it that's cool yeah
hey safe travels and congrats again on
the Vanilla Ice project its season 8 on
DIY great to check up check in with you
thanks for joining us always a pleasure
Dan have a great day behind that's a Rob
Van Winkle otherwise known as vanilla
ice for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]